ah
porque tanta fila son los artistas de
acabados en la barra de ensaladas es un
fractal eso creó la figura abombada se
repite a sí misma creo que deberíamos
hablar de esto en otro lugar
soy vez y soy una artista de acabados y
yo soy anna también soy artista shader
esta elección es acerca de patrones los
cuales usamos en rating o acabados todo
el tiempo
hey ding es crear la superficie de todas
las cosas que ves en nuestras películas
carros dichos árboles extraterrestres
todos empiezan como modelos
tridimensionales pero sin ninguna
característica en sus superficies
nosotros creamos y aplicamos las
texturas que dan una apariencia real a
los personajes y escenarios y la palabra
apariencia aquí es muy importante porque
no estamos intentando recrear la
realidad estamos intentando capturar las
cualidades esenciales que hacen que una
superficie sea verosímil y en muchas
ocasiones esa cualidad es un patrón
cuando empezamos a crear una superficie
por lo regular iniciamos observando
referencias imágenes o cosas de la vida
real observamos algunas cualidades el
color la iluminación que es cómo
reacciona la superficie a la luz y el
relieve qué tan áspera o lisa es
hablemos de cómo hicimos esto con arlo
en el viaje de arlo el personaje debía
verse joven y fresco
de hecho usamos una planta suculenta del
género titán opsis como referencia para
su piel observando de cerca
pudimos deconstruir lo que parecía
adecuado para dar lo primero observamos
una serie de celdas que forman el rasgo
principal del patrón en términos del
color estas celdas tienen un solo color
y el anillo alrededor de la celda tiene
un color más obscuro la superficie de la
planta era brillosa pero no era un
brillo fuerte sino un brillo suave
finalmente las celdas que forman el
patrón principal son un relieve en la
superficie algo irregular una vez que
conocimos estas características
principales empezamos a formar un patrón
ahora para darle al patrón un toque
orgánico necesita vamos a hacer algo más
agregar dispersión una dispersión que
parezca real puede ser muy difícil de
lograr con la computación gráfica las
computadoras son excelentes modelando
patrones regulares pero en la naturaleza
la mayoría de los patrones que ves
tienen alguna variación o irregularidad
en su estructura dando esta sensación de
dispersión controlada conseguir esa
dispersión para la caba donarlo fue un
gran reto pero utilizamos algunas
técnicas interesantes que compartiremos
contigo en lo que resta de la lección
podrás utilizar la dispersión para crear
tus propios patrones apuesto a que
después de esto todos mirarán el mundo a
través de los ojos de un artista de
acabado oye miramos el patrón de
burbujas en este plano